Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Chinese Fantasy Romance film
called “Oversize Love.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Xiaoxi is a young photographer who owns
an at-home studio somewhere in east China.
She is always around beautiful women
for shoots which makes her extremely
insecure about her overweight body. Although
Xiaoxi has tried many methods to lose weight,
she never seems to be successful. As a
hobby, she loves chasing after celebrities.
Her current obsession is an actor and model named
Huangke. While reading one of his interviews,
she comes across a comment claiming that he only
likes girls who are forty-five kgs or below. Right
after, Xiaoxi gets on the scale and sees that she
is almost double the weight. Her friend asks her
to not feel bad about her body because she has
managed to land a handsome friend like Han.
Han has been Xiaoxi's companion since middle
school. He is currently a famous music producer
and is still best friends with her. When Xiaoxi's
friend suggests she date him, she claims that they
are just friends. Deep down, she believes that
Han would never be with someone like her.
Han and Xiaoxi have a tradition of meeting
at the park every Saturday to exercise.
When her friend reminds her of the date, Xiaoxi
rushes to the park. A flashback shows us the
day Han and Xiaoxi met for the first time. In
contrast to now, Han used to be the overweight
one in middle school. He was bullied regularly by
his classmates but couldn't speak up for himself.
He also didn’t have many friends, so when
Xiaoxi saved him from the bullies one day,
he instantly became attached to her. She was
the first person to recognize his musical talent
and the one who made him pursue his dreams.
Back in the present, they meet at a park to
exercise. Half an hour into the workout, Xiaoxi
falls to the ground. As per the tradition,
they go to their favorite street-side restaurant
and eat a lot of food. The bystanders are shocked
to see the amount of food Xiaoxi can eat alone
but it doesn’t bother Han in the least. He has
never had a problem with her weight and
always tells her she is beautiful.
One day, the friends go shopping for clothes.
Buying clothes has always been difficult for
Xiaoxi as an overweight woman. She tries on
a white dress that tears down the neckline
because of her size. She embarrassingly
has to buy it because of the damage.
On their way back home, Han asks her what she
wants for her birthday but Xiaoxi jokes that
she wants a handsome man to date her.
After the two separate, Xiaoxi finds an
abandoned rabbit on the road. She feels bad for
it and brings it home but fails to notice that
its eyes are glowing. The following morning, a
crew of people knock at her door wanting to shoot
in the studio because of a last-minute change.
She allows them after finding out the model of the
shoot is her celebrity crush Huangke. The entire
shoot feels like a dream to her. Later, Huangke
tells her that she has pretty eyes and could be a
model if she loses weight. But then, she overhears
his assistant calling her ugly, asking him to
stay away from people like her for his image.
Starting the next day, she wraps her legs
with plastic, eats healthy, takes supplements,
and exercises harder than ever. But even after two
weeks of hard work she barely loses one kilogram.
That night, she accidentally breaks the sofa with
her weight and falls flat to the ground. As she
lies hopelessly, she notices the rabbit moving
around, almost like it is leading her somewhere.
She follows the animal and reaches an abandoned
mansion in the neighborhood. When she enters
the house, the floor swallows her into a colorful
upside-down room. Xiaoxi panics and tries to move
but gravity doesn’t seem to work in the room.
Then, an old man appears in front of her,
asking her to make a wish. Initially, Xiaoxi
freaks out and tries to run away but the lack
of gravity only makes her float. When she calms
down, the man gives her a blue potion called the
Dream Fixer. It is supposed to make her dream come
true in an instant. Although skeptical at first,
Xiaoxi takes a gulp of it and goes to bed. When
she wakes up the next morning, she can almost
not recognize herself in the mirror. Her body
has shrunk significantly, making her slim. For
a few minutes, she lays on the bed, trying to
take everything in. Then, she gets a call from
her friend asking her to bring the pictures from
the last photoshoot to Huangke’s assistant.
When none of her clothes fit, Xiaoxi wears the
one that she had to buy because of the damage.
On her way to Huangke’s hotel, the people she
knew before do not recognize her while the
bypassers turn around to admire her beauty.
Similarly, Huangke is also smitten by her. He
comments that he has seen her before but doesn’t
know where. Suddenly, Xiaoxi’s chest starts
getting bigger followed by her back. Realizing
that she is turning back to her older self,
she runs away without an explanation.
At night, she again takes the potion and by the
morning, she gets skinny for the second time. Han
arrives at the house worried because she hasn’t
picked up her phone for an entire day. He barges
in to see her wearing a headscarf. Initially, she
pretends to be Xiaoxi’s friend to avoid explaining
the situation but Han recognizes her instantly.
He had never seen her as less beautiful because
of her weight so even though she is significantly
thin, he doesn’t notice much difference.
Xiaoxi tells him about the potion and what it does
to the human body. Han doesn’t want to believe
it but the result is right in front of him.
Minutes later, she yet again turns fat and
finds out that the effect of the potion
only lasts for ten hours. Han doesn’t like
that she is changing her body unnaturally.
He also feels jealous of the actor Huangke knowing
that she took the potion to impress him.
Han’s assistant who is in the fashion
industry takes it upon himself to give
Xiaoxi a makeover. After a week of trying
out different hairstyles and facials,
Xiaoxi turns into a beautiful young woman, a
complete contrast from how she was prior.
Meanwhile, Han hires Huangke to model for his
next music video. On the set, Huangke claims
that he doesn’t feel the chemistry with the female
lead and wants someone who is prettier. Offended,
the female lead quits and storms off the set.
Just then, Xiaoxi arrives looking more stunning
than ever. Huangke suggests they use her as the
model since she has the body and face for it.
Initially, Han doesn’t approve of it but when the
director supports the idea, he has no way but to
agree. For the next week, the team meets every
day for the shoot. Xiaoxi fangirls over Huangke,
making Han jealous. He takes his frustration out
by pointing out little flaws in Huangke's acting
and making him take several shots. An unsaid
rivalry is established between the guys. One day,
the director adds a kissing scene to the script.
Han is absolutely against the idea so instead,
he makes them cover their faces with an umbrella
to make it look like they are kissing.
The following day, Huangke invites Xiaoxi out on
a date. They go to the movies but notice that Han
is right behind their seat. When asked what
he is doing there, he claims that it is only
a coincidence. Everywhere the couple goes,
he follows behind, acting like he is going
the same way. Even when they book a private
cabin at a restaurant, he stands by the door
to keep an eye on them. When it starts to get
dark, Xiaoxi wants to return home but Huangke
insists she come to a party with his friends.
A few minutes into meeting his friend group,
her fingers start to swell, followed by her
entire arm. She rushes to the bathroom and hides
inside a stall crying hysterically. Outside,
Huangke and his friends are waiting for her,
leaving her no way to escape. Just when the
truth is about to be outed, Han comes to save
her in a mascot costume. He makes her wear it
and brings her out without Huangke noticing.
Huangke sees Han talking to another overweight
woman and claims that he can do much better than
a random fat girl. Xiaoxi hears the comment and
is left disheartened. She knows that Huangke only
likes her because of her beauty but cannot seem
to let go of the idea of them being together.
Han drops her home and tells her that she is
not the person she used to be. He also assures
her she will get plenty of guys even if she
remains the way she is. Xiaoxi knows he is lying
because even he could never see her as more than
a friend. A flashback reveals that in high school,
Xiaoxi was in love with Han. But one day, she
overheard Han’s friend making fun of her and
Han saying that he doesn’t like her in that way.
She stopped trying to pursue him after that.
Later, Han and his friend are drinking when the
guy asks him if he regrets not asking Xiaoxi out
when she was still fat. Han remembers the
time in high school when he heard Xiaoxi
tell her friends that she had no feelings
for him. Because of the miscommunication,
they never expressed their feelings to each
other even though they were in love.
The following evening, their filing crew
meets at a restaurant to celebrate the
last day of the shoot. Han and Huangke meet in
the bathroom and get into a slight altercation.
The conflict quickly turns into a physical
fight. The others from the crew have to drag
them away from each other to stop them.
Later, Han and Xiaoxi walk back home together.
He asks her to think about how Huangke will
react if she goes back to being fat.
In turn, Xiaoxi claims that Han hasn’t
treated her any better. When she mentions
the time he was bullied, Han’s eyes glow as the
rabbit’s did earlier. Xiaoxi doesn’t notice it,
distracted by the fact that he
doesn’t remember getting bullied.
In the next scene, Xiaoxi and Huangke are out
on a dinner date. Xiaoxi asks him if he would
like her the same if she were to gain weight.
Huangke replies that they should talk about
positive things like her upcoming acting career.
It is clear to her that he won’t think twice
before leaving her if he sees her real self. After
dinner, she goes to the old mansion yet again and
asks the miracle man for a permanent potion.
He gives her the potion but warns her that it will
cause a side effect on her life that she might
not like. Blinded by the need to be Huangke’s
girlfriend, Xiaoxi takes the potion. At the
same time, Han starts to lose memories of her.
He only remembers that she was someone
he used to know in his childhood.
The next day is the release-day of the music
video. Xiaoxi walks into a hall for a press
conference when she notices the crew looking at
her differently. She tries talking to Huangke
but he ignores her. When they are surrounded
by the reporters, she finds out that the rumor
about her getting liposuction has circulated
on the internet. Since being seen with her
is not a good PR move for Huangke, he announces
that he is in a relationship with someone else.
Some fans in the crowd throw their drink
at Xiaoxi for lying about her beauty.
Han saves her from the media and brings her
upstairs. Xiaoxi soon realizes that he only
remembers the overweight Xiaoxi and thinks that he
hasn’t met her for a while. She tries to show him
their pictures together but her face is missing in
all of them. She breaks down crying but Han thinks
she is in shock from what happened earlier.
A week later, Huangke comes to her house. She
welcomes him in, expecting him to apologize but
he asks her to convince Han to sell him a song.
On finding out he just wants to use her for
her influence, she asks him to get out.
Following the encounter, Xiaoxi rushes to his
office and finds a picture of them from high
school. She finally realizes that she never
stopped loving Han and has been suppressing
her feelings till now. After that, she goes
to the abandoned house again, this time to ask
the man to send her back to her normal self.
The man gives her a last chance and allows her to
transform. After turning fat again, Xiaoxi
runs to the playground and meets Han. When
he calls her by her name, she breaks down
crying, relieved that he remembers her.
One year later, the couple is at their
favorite street-side restaurant. By now,
Xiaoxi has turned fit while Han has gained a
significant amount of weight. The movie ends as
she tells him that she loves him either way.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.